a youth soccer team and their coach
trapped in a cave in Thailand say
they're doing okay
the boys aged 11 to 16 have been stuck
underground by floodwaters for 11 days
then Tracy is in Shanghai Thailand near
the cave complex where efforts to free
the boys are intensifying Ben good
morning good morning so officials here
tell us that they don't plan to try to
attempt to rescue the boys today because
it is simply still too dangerous but a
team of Thai Navy SEALs and medics are
inside the cave with them meanwhile out
here crews are trying to devise a plan
to safely get them out one by one the
boys wrapped in foil warming blankets
took turns introducing themselves and
delivering a message to their parents
that they're in good health
some of them smiled and held up peace
signs as a medic treated scratches on
their feet and legs
the boys appeared more alert than a day
ago when British divers discovered them
on a muddy ledge and while enthusiasm is
high the complicated task of how they
will all be safely rescued from the cave
remains unclear hey Coast looks off
taken at 9:00 this morning Cheng Rhys
governor suggested that the team might
not all be able to leave at the same
time rescue crews are weighing the
option of having the boys swim out
immediately but that remains the
riskiest choice the team is trapped
about two and a half miles from the
entrance to the cave to get out they
would need to navigate through areas
that require full climbing gear several
flooded sections parts too narrow to
wear a scuba tank and a nearly 100 foot
underwater dive it's a difficult task
for even the most experienced divers let
alone a group of boys who don't know how
to swim so the plan for now is this they
are trying to furiously pump as much
water out of this cave as possible the
hope is if they bring the water level
down far enough it'll be more safe for
the kids to either try to swim out or
better yet they could wade or walk out
in the meantime a phone line is being
installed inside the cave so the young
soccer players can finally talk to their
parents
the mother of a trap 16 year old said it
feels like her son has been given a new
life this has become a race against time
and the weather heavy rains are forecast
for this weekend again so they are in
the process of trying to plug every hole
they can find that goes into this cave
so it doesn't flood again Anthony Van
Tracy and Thailand still so many
questions first of all about how these
kids ended so ended up so deep into that
cave without heeding the warnings from
the Sun and I mean how they will finally
get out in a moment I mean the monsoon
season in Southeast Asia is incredibly
serious we're talking about a huge
volume of what goes on till October and
what those parents went through and what
they continue to do that yeah alright
Ben Tracy it's always good to get Ben's
reports live on the ground